>> THIS REPORT DID NOT FIND ANY
EVIDENCE OF POLITICAL BIAS OR
IMPROPER CONSIDERATIONS ACTUALLY
IMPACTING THE INVESTIGATION
UNDER REVIEW.
THE REPORT DOES IDENTIFY ERRORS
OF JUDGMENT VIOLATIONS OF OR
EVEN DISREGARD FOR POLICY AND IT
DECISIONS THAT THE VERY LEAST,
WITH THE BENEFIT OF HINDSIGHT,
WERE NOT THE BEST CHOICES.
WE WILL ADHERE TO THE
APPROPRIATE DISCIPLINARY
PROCESS, AND ONCE THAT PROCESS
IS COMPLETE WE WON'T HESITATE TO
HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR ACTIONS.
>> Bret: AT THE FBI DIRECTOR
CHRIS WRAY REACTING TO THE
REPORT FROM THE DOJ.
568 PAGES, AND IN IT, JIM COMEY
TAKES IT ON THE CHIN.
ALONG WITH SOME OTHERS IN THERE.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL,
CHARLES HURT, OPINION EDITOR FOR
"THE WASHINGTON TIMES," CHARLES
LANE, OPENING WRITER FOR
"THE WASHINGTON POST," AND
MATTHEW CONTINETTI, EDITOR AND
CHIEF OF "THE WASHINGTON
FREE BEACON."
CHARLIE, WHAT DO YOU TAKE FROM
THIS REPORT, YOUR REACTION TO IT
AND WHERE WE ARE GOING?
>> Charles: I THINK THE MOST
INTERESTING THING IS, TOP LINE,
YOU HAVE PEOPLE SAYING THERE IS
NO EVIDENCE OF POLITICAL BIAS IN
THE WHOLE PROCESS, WHICH IS
STRANGE CREDULITY TO THINK ABOUT
THAT.
AB THERE IS NO SMOKING GUN WHERE
JAMES COMEY SAID BLATANTLY, I
WANT TO RAKE THIS THING SO THAT
HILLARY CLINTON WINS AND
DONALD TRUMP LOSES.
BUT ALL THROUGHOUT -- THIS WHOLE
REPORT SHOWS AT RAMPANT
POLITICAL BIAS, ALL UP AND DOWN
THE SYSTEM.
WHETHER IT'S PETER STRZOK AND
HIS STAR-CROSSED LEVER, OR
LORETTA LYNCH AND HER DECISION
TO PUNT ON THE ENTIRE THING
AFTER THE MEETING ON THE TARMAC
WITH BILL CLINTON, AND THE WHOLE
THING TO JAMES COMEY, OR ALL THE
OTHER CHARACTERS THAT CLEARLY
HAD AN UNMISTAKABLE BIAS HERE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU STOP AND
CONSIDER THE FINAL DECISION THAT
THEY MADE WHEN JAMES COMEY COMES
OUT AND GIVES THIS WITHERING
INDICTMENT, AND SAYS, BUT WE ARE
NOT GOING TO INDICT HER.
>> Bret: SPEAKING OF LORENZO
LYNCH, I TALKED TO HER AND SPOKE
TO HER ABOUT THE EMAIL CASE.
WHO IS THE ULTIMATE DECIDER AT
THE DOJ?
>> IT DEPENDS ON HOW THE MATTER
COMES TOGETHER.
ESSENTIALLY IT WILL BE REVIEWED
BY THOSE CAREER INDEPENDENT
AGENCY LAWYERS THAT I MENTIONED
AND THEY WILL MAKE A
COMMENDATION AS TO WHAT THEY
HAVE DISCOVERED AND WHAT THEY
RECOMMENDED.
>> Bret: BUT THE UP OR DOWN,
YES OR NO, GOING FORWARD OR NOT,
IS THAT YOU?
>> IT DEPENDS ON WHAT THEY FIND.
>> IT WASN'T HER.
>> I THINK SHE COMES OFF NOT TOO
HOT IN THIS REPORT BECAUSE HER
INABILITY TO SORT OF RESOLVE ONE
OR THE OTHER, AND I EITHER GOING
TO RECUSE BECAUSE I MET WITH
BILL CLINTON ON THE TARMAC, OR
AM I GOING TO STAY IN AND TAKE
THE HEAT?
SHE NEVER CAME TO REST ON THAT
POINT WHICH CREATED THE OPENING
FOR JANE CALL           JIM COMY
FOR JANE CALL           JIM COMT
FOR JANE CALL           JIM COMO
FOR JANE CALL           JIM COMC
FOR JANE CALL           JIM COMM
FOR JANE CALL           JIM COME
FOR JANE CALL           JIM COMA
FOR JANE CALL           JIM COMO
FOR JANE CALL           JIM COMG
FOR JANE CALL           JIM COM,
WHICH OF COURSE THE AJI CLAIMS
IS TOTAL VIOLATION OF PROCEDURE.
MY TAKE ON THIS REPORT IS, IT
SHOWS THAT THERE IS A LITTLE BIT
OF THIS IN IT FOR EVERYONE.
I KNOW HILLARY AND TRUMP ARE
LOOKING AT THIS VINDICATION,
CLAIMING THAT IT SHOWS CLEARLY
THAT JIM COMEY INTERVENED IN
THIS THING IMPROPERLY AND THAT
HURT HILLARY'S CHANCES FOR THE
ELECTION.
I THINK IT IS JUST STANDARD
OPERATING PROCEDURE, YOU DON'T
COMMENT ON AN ONGOING
INVESTIGATION IF YOU ARE THE
FLATFOOT DOING THE INVESTIGATION
FLATFOOT DOING THE INVESTIGATIO
INVESTIGATION.
COMEY THOUGHT IT WAS HIS
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO SOMEHOW
USURP THOUGHT, AND THAT'S NOT MY
WORD BUT THIS IG'S WORD, USE
HER.
HE DID IT WITHOUT DISCUSSING
WITH HIS SUPERIORS AND THAT'S
PRETTY HEAVY STUFF.
>> Bret: THE REVELATION OF
THIS OTHER TEXT BETWEEN LISA
PAGE AND PETER STRZOK, THE
SECOND PART OF IT THAT COMES OUT
JUST A COUPLE WEEKS AGO, NO, NO
HE WON'T.
REFERRING TO TRUMP BEING
PRESIDENT.
WE WILL STOP IT, STRZOK RESPONSE
TO PAIGE.
THAT IS DONE BEFORE THE DECISION
TO A SLOW WALK THE INVESTIGATION
INTO ANTHONY WEINER'S -- OF THE
EMAILS ON HIS COMPUTER.
AND THE IG SAYS, THAT'S A PLACE
WHERE THE POLITICAL VIRUS COULD
HAVE INFECTED THIS ENTIRE THING.
>> AND IT WAS ALSO DONE RIGHT
AROUND THE TIME THAT WE KNOW
THAT THE OTHER INVESTIGATION,
CROSS FIRE HURRICANE, WAS BEING
OPENED INTO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
AND STRZOK WAS INVOLVED IN BOTH
OF THEM.
AT 558 PAGES, IT'S LIKE THE WAR
AND PEACE OF JUDGMENT.
EVERYONE, FROM HILLARY CLINTON
WHO STARTED THIS WITH THE EMAILS
ON A CLASSIFIED SERVER TO EMAILS
BETWEEN STRZOK AND PAGE,
INCLUDING JAMES COMEY, INCLUDING
ANDREW McCABE, INCLUDING SOME
HALF-DOZEN OFFICIALS THAT HAVE
BEEN REASSIGNED OR RETIRED SENSE
OF SCANDAL HAS DEVELOPED, THEY
ALL EXERCISED GREAT MISJUDGMENT.